do you mind if I fight somebody no you
were a squirrel all right so I don't
know anything about older Warcraft I
don't do the charge attack one ok tell
me when I can party dude I'm a third
party you this ain't cool man I was
gonna get him - I had him whatever you
do just don't die
[Music]
hey guys I'm hitting the road again this
time I'm heading to New Orleans the home
of the pelicans to check out Josh arts
battle station my name is Doug sensor
Martin I'm a professional gamer and a
four-time Call of Duty champion when I'm
gaming at home this is my battle station
where I play I'm excited to get to
Louisiana to see what Hearts looks like
Josh Hart is a shooting guard for his
new team the New Orleans pelicans Josh
Hart gets a good look off the court he
plays Walter Warcraft he's also new to
gaming on PC I've been a console gamer
my whole life so I'm here in the Big
Easy to get a crash course from heart
and PC gaming and get a good look at his
battle station what's up John my boy
behind him any good I'm good luck
playing you got a nice spot there thank
you I know I'd default supposed to close
the door or not so I said oh I just let
that [ __ ] open you just moved here two
weeks ago right yeah what's your
favorite part about this place the
campfire I never had a campfire before
and I've always wanted one
you got your Chelsea Jersey on you
watching some soccer on the Sunday man
so I'm diehard so I get up I put the
whole outfit on you gonna think like I'm
about to go like I'm about to go play in
the Matthew I just gotta say man I've
watched you since feeling over since day
one I want to know more about you I want
to see her gaming setup but I also wanna
know how you game
a set up man this is sick you got your
little like arcade thing here the corner
NBA Jam probably played this probably
twice I don't know what I'm doing but
hey it's just taking up space right here
got the good lighting we got the door
this guy switch with the blue and the
red Dan he other players on the team
have like a switch how that ended my
rookie year he played with him
besa Zuba Larry Nance Jr I actually just
got a gaming laptop so I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be bringing down on the road you
got everything you need right in front
of you can you just go in-depth about
all of your favorite things that you got
going on right now
I would love to please enlighten me
so console will hooked up to this
monitor so I'll play Madden FIFA
whatever I played on that and then this
would be my PC monitors I'm a keyboard
and mouse a boat from rokai the road
cats a German brand Turtle Beach
actually bought them so I was amateur
the beach guy so I think this keyboard
as it just came out I don't know
anything about it but I like how it
looks in bad things idea why I got it
but like that just sounds so nice and
then this PC sort of beats build it they
gave to me and I was very happy that
they did that they run it very smoothly
where do video games talk to you it
started when I was young when I was a
kid I like pie like seven seven eight
what was your first game and you
remember playing ready every seven like
super mario nintendo 64 it's all about
the one we has to like save Princess
Peach yeah
now only like still that still like one
of my favorite games pokémon to played
on my gameboy every game boy advance
then they came out with their little
attachment light so I could just be up
all night when I was supposed to be
sleeping I like you don't have to turn
actual light on you're gonna plug a
little light in from the top and like
bend it over the screen you can like
play during that it's a desk when like
Pokemon really took off that was the
exact same for me too actually
that was before they had the Game Boy SP
were in the way and I used to love
turning the light on just to see the
light go on and I thought it was
incredible you told me everything about
you said I greased up for your chair
give you your chair turn B to max anomic
game of the chair so it's very
comfortable it's cozy do you ever take a
second with you here and just like in
between games like maximum progress I'm
just like yes do you know about this
though do you know what this is bro well
I'll tell you I know nothing else is
right nothing I mean that's something
that helps with the sound this is what
learn like PC gamers and they're so
particular with all it like the specs
and the keyboard how they feel and all
that I'm really basic I guess new
because I haven't really played PC like
that I've really been a month has been a
month since you started yeah but then I
was traveling I was doing all the stuff
so I bought a laptop you always doing
stuff in my laptop yeah so I honestly
like last night was the first time I got
back like on there like this X was set
up as you can see still getting used to
Maya no one was like so how difficult is
it for you to go from console to PC it's
difficult just because you got like
basically retrain your fingers to move
that kind of way I get way more accurate
master keyboard than you are with
joysticks under control I've been
grinding all while trying to like get my
PC wave going it takes a little while
but I like it it's more accurate I'm a
PC noob so I've never played PC other
than the story
what a Warcraft I've never played this
game either I like sports I like
first-person shooters cod you know
fortnight but I like slowly started
really liking this game there's so many
different kind of players you can be
sort of two sides or within the Alliance
so I'm a horde like you're you're just
trying to quest level up you can PvP
against people likes your guy right here
yes my dude
a little orc warrior good name of the
game is your fine stuff then you can
lure them so I'm just like run up and
we're just going blow for blow can I do
that right now
all right I want to see what is that
thing I'm a big charger how many hours a
day do you play what a walk right I
played a couple out of the day now I'm
nothing crazy actually I'll play this
and then he's right in front of you
that's licensed all right so now what
we're gonna do Josh we're gonna play
never have I ever
gaming edition so every single time I
ask you one of these if you've done one
of these in the past
you got any some Mike and Ikes alright
alright so first one never have I ever
used a cheat code in a video game what
game was it yeah yeah you owe me - never
have I ever stayed up for more than 24
hours gaming 25 consecutively yes no I
consecutively
I got your muscly never have I ever rage
quit during a video game it like broke
or through our controllers can you
finish the question I got my own Twitter
Mike thrown a controller
I did out on land once to in a match and
we got four nests out of a game I threw
the headset the monitor and how'd you
find me thanks you have give you some
like nice Fisher lemon oh good Wi-Fi
somebody know you were a squirrel all
right so I don't know anything about oil
to work right I'm going to try some WASD
yeah I don't do the charge attack one
okay because no don't do that Alliance I
can't I can't get him no no he go with
the ass okay tell me what I can party
dude I'm a third party this ain't cool
man I was gonna get him - I had him
whatever you do just don't where's the
best gamer in the NBA for tonight me oh
gee I think Ben Simmons is big on Punky
Wow
probably me cuz I think I'm the only one
ever plays Wow - came added I don't even
know I don't even play okay the Aaron
said the same thing - emotive most
played only thing please don't play okay
call it a hard I probably like the air
you're the best Call of Duty player in
the NBA nine plus you're claiming right
now on camera this is official that you
are the best NBA player that plays
called even the best players worse to be
honest do you play video games with any
other athletes yeah when I played 14 up
late I was I had like this twitch him I
did on like Sundays and it was called
ballers only and it's fun yeah up 2mv a
guy throw soccer guys football guys I
played with carny two towns Larry Nance
Reggie Jackson Terrance Ross rondae
hollis-jefferson it's cool just because
it's a different side of you know the
athlete I think I probably why like me
and Larry Nance oh it's a good
relationship just because we played
video games for hours quick go quick
doves I can't tell you how many hours we
played play together playing video games
now when you're on the court know this
it's all it's always business but then
when you get off the court you know you
play video game to kind of dive into
their personal life be able to see
people in different lights and you're
able to have a better chemistry with
those guys and they need to transfer it
onto the court so anyone the one that
they ask what how that
somebody want to go don't go I might be
if I'm 11:28 but I might be able to get
just level 30 spark show towards he's
chasing is run no this is what haven't
you died
one last thing before we go I have a
surprise to my crew set something up for
you
cool cool let's do it Oh perfectly on
cue there it is this is though we got
the old school space invaders we want to
know if you could beat my high score
dude we're gonna go do it
have you played space invaders before
there's been a long time okay
can I get this dude can we knock them
all out
you got one nice life one nice life
getting really close to oh my god the
pressures on men as a pleasure they're
not begging man
thanks again dude I'll see you later man
bye as you walk off into the sunset yep
hey I'm Josh Hart thank you guys for
watching battle stations
make sure you guys subscribe to the
police report Channel